i'm now in austin texas
my good friend joe rogan
he's been highlighting to me
this aggressive uh
marketing on mainstream media channels
by pfizer so let me ask the general
marketing question
do you see this as a conflict of
interest is it my bias the reporting of
news
that a lot of us a lot of people
me included look to these
mainstream channels of news
for kind of authority of like what the
heck's going on in the world
and
if pfizer is sponsoring
uh
many of these shows
there's a worry
it may be a perception thing but there's
also natural worry that they would
influence what they're talking about
because they're afraid of losing the
sponsorship it's subtle
but
at scale it might have a serious impact
do you worry about this
i think people could go one way or
another
because of multiple reasons
from our perspective we
i don't think we have aggressive
marketing
what do we do we go on tv and we are
having
ads about our products
and
they are highly regulated
i think it is the right of people to
know to learn that if there is a product
like that it's very
clearly that we cannot say things
that they are off-label that have not
been approved we need to have every time
we go on tv as you know fda is forcing
us to say also the bad things that can
happen for a medicine sometimes that
takes more time
than the good things
and i don't think that we are doing
aggressive marketing
no people could be influenced
in and can be biased in in the podcasts
or in the other type of media
activities that they have for multiple
different reasons
yeah i know but it's still it's pressure
it's human nature i mean i i it's one of
his perception but i worry about too i
think i have a ton of sponsors for this
podcast for example and none of them
ever asked me to
anything they're just you know
i think
likely that kind of pressure is not
happening for pfizer
but there's implied pressure sometimes
and i worry about that a lot
because
you know i look at academia
like i i look for the good in people i
tend to believe most people are good or
have the capacity to be good and desire
to be good uh when i came to mit i
i was a little bit um
disappointed maybe heartbroken
how much pressure
um
i think unjustified pressure people felt
from financial constraints
especially at mit when there's i think a
lot of money
people still felt constraints and they
weren't
it wasn't bringing out the best in them
they weren't supporting each other they
weren't loving each other like
celebrating each other's successes
i don't want to blame money on
everything money constraints but
when you have sponsors it just um
i personally worry that doesn't bring
the best out of people
and so
i feel like i want to put some
responsibility on sponsors and and great
big companies
like pfizer to to kind of uh
not
get in the way of the best of human
nature whether it's sponsoring uh
podcasts
mainstream media
like i don't know athletes whatever
you need to know that we are so so
careful with sponsorships first of all
we have very few very very few
we have a team that for every single one
could be two thousand dollars
they will try to see if there is a
conflict of interest in the way we do it
and also what is the reputation
of the
of
the the persons or the programs that we
are sponsoring so
i don't think
our friend i think was from texas
yes yeah i don't care rogan yes yes
i don't think he got it right that we do
those type of things
we don't oh in terms of manipu like
having a negative effect on not even
having aggressive sponsorships we have
very few
yeah when you clip them all together and
most of the sponsorship that we have it
is more on patient related organizations
right rather than we are very careful
not to sponsor other things that can be
perceived not even
influenced but perceived that we may
influence so we are very very careful on
that this is not the case with us
you